so it's time to examine uncountable sets
that's what we're gonna do in this
segment so Cantor's question was are all
sets the same size and he gives a
definitive answer of null Cantus theorem
which were about present will show that
in fact there isn't any biggest infinity
for any given infinity you can find a
bigger one in a very simple way but
let's begin by coming up with a the
simplest form of Cantor's diagonal
argument of how do you prove that a set
is not countable well remember a set is
countable if you can list it possibly
with repeats so a is countable if
there's a sequence a0 a1 a2 such that
every element in the set a shows up at
some time or other in the list possibly
more than once and the only things in
the list are elements of a and we saw as
an example that the finite bit strings
the finite strings of zeros and ones or
the finite binary words are an example
of a countable set and we claimed last
time and now we're about to prove that
the difference is that if you look at
the infinite bit strings they well NY
infinite they have a beginning and they
go on infinitely the right the notation
being 0 went to the Omega where Omega is
an indication of one of the symbols for
kind of infinity and this is going to be
an example of an uncountable set how
we're going to prove that well the set
up for using a diagonal argument is to
think about drawing a matrix suppose
that I have some way of enumerated the
infinite binary sequences the in 0 1 to
the Omega so there's a sequence s0
there's a sequence s1 there's a sequence
s2 let's lay them out as though they
were the rows of a matrix so s0 is this
infinite binary sequence 0 0 1 0 and so
on and the column labels are simply the
coordinate labels for s 0 so this is s 0
0 s 0 1 and so
s1 is the next infinite binary sequence
in this hypothetical list and it starts
0 1 1 0 and goes on and so on down the
line so the row labels are this
enumeration of binary sequences and the
column labels are coordinate labels and
this is a matrix that's infinite to the
right and infinite down but it
definitely has an upper left corner so
the trick is to try to find an infinite
binary sequence that is not in this list
that it differs from every row if I can
do that then I've shown that any attempt
to enumerate all of the binary sequences
in 0 went to the Omega any sequence like
s0 s1 and s2 of binary sequences is
missing something which means you can't
really list it well how do you find
something that's missing something how
do you find a sequence that's not here
well pretty easy you look at the first
digit and that was a 0 so you choose the
first digit of the new sequence to be 1
the opposite of 0 and you choose the
second digit to be the opposite of the
coordinate of s the FIR of a digit 1 of
s1 and complement that now here the
digit 2 of s 2 is a 0 so let's make that
a 1 and the next one on the diagonal is
a 0 and so on we're going to complement
all other bits along this diagonal so I
get a diagonal sequence that's why this
argument is called a diagonal argument
well let's think about this diagonal
sequence Jusuf gate goes on right down
the diagonal of this 2-dimensional
infinite matrix what we can say about it
is that it differs from every row why is
that well it differs from the 15th row
at the 15th position where coordinate 15
it difference from the 99th row at
coordinate 99 it's not in the matrix
it's not a row of any matrix and that
immediately tells you it's over any
attempt to list all of the elements in 0
1 to the Omega is going to omit a
diagonal element it's not possible to
list all of them in other words there
isn't any surjection from
non-negative integers to 0 1 to the
Omega because I've just shown you how if
you give me a surjection of on two
binary sequences in effect I'm giving
you with n a zero sequence of first
sequence of thirds a second sequence and
so on then I know exactly how to find
something that's not there they can't be
a surjection from n 2 0 1 to the Omega
it's just not true and that's why we can
say that the 0 1 to the Omega is
uncountable definition of countable or
an equivalent formulation accountable
remember is that there's a surjection
from the non-negative integers to the
set well there isn't any we just proved
it
ok so n is not search 0 1 by the way
it's also quite easy to see that there
is a subjection from the infinite binary
sequence to the non-negative integers
you could map a binary sequence to the
coordinate of the first one in it and
that maps every infinite binary sequence
to a non-negative integer two hits every
non integer non-negative integer lots of
times I had you know 5 with a sequence
that starts with 4 0 0 1 the only
sequence that doesn't go anywhere is the
all 0 sequence but by the way if you
check the definition of Surge it doesn't
require that the function be total
Serge means that there is a function
that is a surjection to end but it
doesn't have to be granary equal 1 out
arrow out there just has to be less than
or equal to 1 arrow so it's a function
but of course it's easy enough to make
it total the all 0 sequence just map it
to 0 so now you have both the 0 and the
sequence that starts with the sequence
to any sequence that starts with 1 will
all map to 0 ok so oh if we remember our
intuition the surge is read as greater
than or equal to so this tells us that
the infinite binary sequences are a
larger send least as large a set as than
non-negative integers and the converse
is true then non-negative integers are
not at least at least as large as the
infinite binary sequences so we can
really say that the non-negative
integers are strictly smaller than the
set of in
binary sequences necessarily smaller is
in quotes because again we don't know
exactly what the size of infinite sets
is all we're doing really are talking
about properties objections Jirga by G
actually surjections injections okay so
let's make an explicit definition I'm
going to say that a strict B means that
there is no surjection from A to B so if
we read a surjection be intuitively as a
greater equal to B this is saying it's
not true that a is greater equal to B or
in ordinary language and thinking about
sets if it's not true that your greater
than or equal to B you must be strictly
less than B so that's the motivation for
the word strength but remember we're
talking about infinite sets and we can't
go around assuming too many properties
of strict until we've proved them one
non-trivial property by the way is I've
defined strict that it's not true that
there's a surjection from A to B a B but
I'm not insisting that there must be a
surjection from B to A which would be
the second companion part that is a is
not greater angle to B and B is greater
than equal to a it turns out technically
you can prove that if there isn't any
surjection from A to B there will be a
surjection from B to a but that's using
a set theoretic argument that's not so
obvious and we don't need it so this is
the definition of strict a strict B
means you cannot get a surjection from A
to B and we're intuitively reading it as
a is strictly smaller than B and we've
just shown then is that the non-negative
integers strict a 0 1 to the Omega the
infinite binary sequences
okay now Cantus theorem is a wonderful
generalization of this it's a powerful
generalization but the proof is pretty
much the same although and sometimes
looks a little different as it's written
up and what Cantus theorem says is just
it's it's just beautifully elegant and
simple it's it it says simply that the
power set is strictly bigger than the
set a strict power set of a for every
set a even if it is finite because
remember if a is finite you say a has n
elements then the power set of a has to
to the
and elements and you can check then even
for an equal zero and is less than or
equal to two to the N is less than 2 to
the N 0 is less than 2 to the 0 which is
1 2 is less than 2 squared which is 4
and so on so even for finite sets we
have a strict power set of a but the
cool thing is that it works even for
infinite sets let's take a look it's a
diagonal argument again but now I
mustn't assume that a is countable I'm
not going to assume that I can really
list the elements of a but we'll think
about it as though we could let's think
about this matrix again so suppose a is
this set of elements a b st d e I'm
scrambling up the alphabet on purpose
because I don't want you to get the idea
that we're assuming that a is countable
that you can list all the elements of a
I'm not assuming that but I'm just
writing out a sample of elements of a
and let's suppose then I was trying to
get a surjection from a to the power set
of a so suppose I have a function f that
map's each of the successive elements of
a to some subset of a so f of a is a
this part of the power said it's a
subset of capital a f of b is a subset
of capital a and so on and suppose I had
a set up like this I'm gonna draw a
matrix that looks like the diagonal
matrix and we're going to extract the
diagonal set and discover that that
diagonal said is not one of the FS it's
not f of anything which means that F is
not gonna be a surjection so let's look
at it again so here's this matrix where
I'm labeling the columns of the matrix
by the elements of a no particular order
here but I in order to remain tricks
have to write them down in some order
and likewise the first row is going to
be f of this element a well what is an F
of a F of a is going to be a set of
elements so let's just write the
elements in F of a down under the
corresponding column label so here's an
example where F of a it has an A in it
and no B but it has an S in it and a T
in it no see no D it has an e likewise F
of B has an A and B and no S or T but
it's got a C and so on so I filled in
this
by taking f of an element in a which is
supposed to be a subset of a and writing
out all of the elements in that subset
under the corresponding a letter or a
other corresponding element the of the
subset so B goes under a B if it's in F
of C and s goes under an S if it's in F
of C nothing goes under at a if T is not
in F of C that's what we're seeing here
so I'm laying out as though I was using
zeros and ones for an infinite binary
sequence I'm laying out each of the sets
of that that are in the range of F along
in this row and now with this set up I
can define a new set which is not going
to be an F how do I get that well what
I'm gonna do is not in my new set I'm
not gonna have any of the elements that
appear on the diagonal so if a is a
member of F of a that means that a
appears in this coordinate it's not
gonna be in my set if B is in F of B
meaning that B appears in that B appears
in the F of B row under the column B
it's not gonna be in my set on the other
hand s is not in F of s because there's
no s there so I'm gonna put an S there
in magenta and likewise I'm gonna stick
elements in or out the opposite of
whether they appear on the diagonal and
this is gonna give me a set B which is
going to be my diagonal set okay so well
if we write this out so what we're
saying is suppose that I have a function
f from a to the power set of a then what
I'm going to do is define a subset of a
that's not in the range of F namely set
B um which is the set of those elements
in a such that little a is not in F of a
namely if if an element appeared on the
diagonal because an element with column
label a was in the row F of a am I left
an atom
set and if it was not in in that
location in the matrix I put it in my
set so I'm keeping all the elements that
aren't in on the diagonal that's my
diagonal set D and what I know about it
is that D is not in the range of F
because it differs from every possible
row of the matrix if the row was labeled
with with F of a as F of a then it
differs in the column a F of a from that
row and therefore my set D is not a row
of this matrix and that means that it's
not equal to F of anything so I've just
found that there's no F arrow into D
these not in the range of F that means
that if I had such an F and from a to
the power set of a it's not a surjection
because D is always left out so f is not
a surjection and since you know F is any
function from a to the power set of a
none of them are surjections and that
means there's no surjection from a from
the power set of a in other words a
strict power set of a there's no
subjection now a special case of this of
course is that the non-negative integers
are strictly smaller than the power set
of n that's an instance of of Cantor's
theorem where we're applying a being the
set of non-negative integers so there's
no surjection from the non-negative
integers to the subsets of non-negative
integers again that means that the power
set of n is an example of an uncountable
set because the definition of countable
is that there would be a surjection from
n to power set of n we're saying there
isn't any so it's not countable or not
countable as so is usually phrased as
uncapped able so the power set of n is
maybe our second example of an
uncountable set the first one being the
infinite sequences of binary numbers now
as a matter of fact there's a just as we
had a general way to prove capability
you can show that a set is countable if
there's a surjection from a set you know
is countable on to the
target them the targets countable take
the country positive of that lemma and
you can say that if a set a is
uncountable and there's a surjection
from C to a then C has to be uncountable
that's just the country positive for the
previous one if C was countable then a
would be countable so if a is
uncountable C must be uncountable so
this gives us again a nice general way
to prove uncountability of sets once I
have a couple in my repertoire well it
means that we could have deduced that 0
1 to the Omega that the infinite binary
sequences were uncountable because we
know that there's a bisection between
the infinite binary sequences in the
power said event we've we describe that
by action without knowing anything about
any other properties of the infinite
binary sequences in the power sight
event whether they were countable or not
but now that Cantor's theorem tells us
that the power said event is uncountable
and there's a bisection the previous
lemma it says in particular there's a
surjection from 0 1 to the Omega to the
power set of n which means 0 1 to the
Omega is uncountable
so in a what I'm illustrating then is
that the proof that we use directly on
by a diagonal argument to figure out
that 0 1 to the Omega was uncountable
it's really a special case of the more
general diagonal argument that we use to
proves Cantor's theorem and we get that
0 1 to the Omega is uncountable as a
consequence of Cantor's theorem about
the power set of N and so we've got two
different ways then to prove that the
infinite binary sequences are
uncountable another example an
uncountable set it's a real numbers and
they're a cute example remember we saw
that the rational numbers were countable
the real numbers are uncountable well
how do I prove that I'm just going to
show you a surjection from the real
numbers onto the infinite binary
sequences how am I going to do that well
it's a kind of snooping trick but it
works I'm using both positive and
negative reals so let's look at some
real number and look at its binary
representation assume for the moment
that it's positive so let's look at say
the binary representation of some number
like 3 and 1/3
that means that if we're thinking of
these as the as binary places this is
the zeroth place the twos place the
Forbes places in the highest place the
quarters place the eighths place then
the binary representation of three and a
third would be three and then this
infinite repeating not decimal but by
now but by simple binary expansion zero
one zero one zero one and we will
examine how I know that that's a third
but take it for granted that that's what
you get is the repeated fraction you can
figure that out by just doing a division
of one by three in binary anyway there
is just as there's a decimal expansion
of every real number
there's a binary expansion just using
base two so here's the binary expansion
of three and a third so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna map three and a third to
this binary sequence I'm going to ignore
the decimal place of binary it's not a
decimal place it's a bessa mole place or
binary position and I'm just gonna take
this to the mapping the sequence 1 1 0 1
0 1 0 1 ok and I claim that this is a
surjection because you're gonna hit
every possible binary sequence in this
way well almost let's take a closer look
there's a problem with mapping to things
that start with 0 because let's examine
that 1/2 is 0.1000
so I would map it to that and and it
will end but there's an ambiguity
because 1/2 is also equal to 0.01 1 1 1
1 just as point nine nine nine nine nine
nine is equal to one point
oooo in decimal you get the same
infinite carry issue here in binary so
numbers that end in all ones have
another way to represent the very same
number by a sequence that ends in all
zeros so how am I gonna hit if I'm using
on behalf the head this one what's left
to hit that one oh how about using minus
1/2 it's there and that's part of our so
I'm just going to map the negative
numbers to the version
the expansion that starts with zero and
has an infinite number of ones and the
positive one that if it ends with an
infinite number of zeros and otherwise
I'm going to map plus and minus numbers
to the same place so this is going to
give me the needed surjection from our
to the infinite binary sequences and by
our previous lemma that implies sure
enough that the real numbers are
uncountable